mitchell kriegman created the show
clarissa explains it all yeah i did
and some other classics yeah i created
bear in the big blue house and i worked
on rugrats ren and stimpy doug rocco
but i love clarissa so we came out here
to talk about it and learned some things
about the show that we probably didn't
know cool
here we go
the latter was i think about four rungs
or something like that it was like about
maybe this high
and sam had to crouch down underneath
the window and go like a mime you know
coming up every time
and he had to slam it on there and we
had to get that guitar sting in of
course
and when they built the set you could
see in the pilot we eventually fixed
this right but the pilot you could see
through the window and see the floor of
the studio
i banned purple
i would never give a reason
and i kind of rationalize it a little
bit by saying you know i'm trying to
appeal to boys and girls and i said well
it's got to be all pink and blue you
know we got to use those in our main
colors and purple throws that off
[ __ ] you know complete [ __ ]
right
they just ignored me after a while
well i can't really tell you is the
problem with that and i've never told
anybody even melissa
i had the most amazing writers i had
suzanne collins who wrote hunger games
alexa young who was one of the main
writers on friends nina bieber wrote
plays and wrote daria i mean these
writers you know all went on to do like
amazing stuff you know
if you're like 26 to 36
you know almost universally if i say i
created clarissa explains it all
they scream like a 14 year old girl
and they say that's my childhood you
made my childhood and those are the
words everybody says it's like my career
is 30 years younger than i am you know
which i love
it's super satisfying it's completely
wonderful